[Music]  i had thought that i was aware of all  your work and then we came across  something uh today that i had never seen  before  it's a workout video that you did then i  didn't even know that you did a workout  video um i've never taken aerobics  before and i was doing an aerobic video  so you did an aerobics video without  ever taking aerobics yes  how did that work they have a little ear  piece in your ear and they're like okay  two to the right two to the left and my  arms are i'm like what am i you're the  teacher yes  let's take a look  back  exhale bring them forward  this is the last time  hip's back  [Music]  [Applause]  that was ridiculous you burned like one  calorie there  i think you invented  [Applause]  mo  twerking